Rini
Noah
reading we got to go to the bunker
we shouldn't stay here
it's cranky dusty I can hardly breathe
it's horrible
we get through this rainy
if Clark said it's not safe here
this clock also said you'd get a black
tongue from cursing too it's safer here
than it is out there anyway we can run
and hide in the woods No or we can run
back to the orphanage
I'm sure Santa Maria waiting for us
we're stuck in here why don't you
understand that anyone still out there
is going to die all of them little girls
aren't invincible they get blown to
pieces too
I didn't mean to rainy I didn't mean to
scare you Rini I'm so sorry
just forget what I said okay you're
senior I promise
what can I do to comfort Rini
you like shadow please don't you
look greenie there's the elephant
dear
well look at that isn't that the sock I
was looking for last week that I can't
find the other one
socks belong together but there's always
one missing
yeah actually kind of sad
an ordinary mirror
maybe there's something nice on alright
let's do something miss Clark totally
wouldn't approve of today's fighting
resulted in mass fatalities with unknown
casualties
it is only certain that aerial
bombardment has not ceased
reminds me Mississippi that never fails
to cheery me Oh
guess who I am
well you don't look like you at all how
about now no you don't even have baubles
and we're spot
where am I supposed to get a bobble hat
not to mention a green super caterpillar
she always got take afraid hey he's got
a bobble head I hate to make a fool of
myself do it Ferrini
hey Rini hello sad lake house spot we'll
ask him yourself when he shows up
someone likes pot isn't that easy to
find
this can make a fine socks pot tada
today's show is all about audience
requests I want a story about silence
really a snow please tell him story a
spottin Sablan all right so this is the
story of sad week and it's world silence
sure and his world he oh sorry
hmm silence sad week was a clown who
never laughed he also didn't want people
to laugh at him so he left his grandpa
his brother and the circus to see the
world but not alone because with him was
his best friend spot spot also have sad
and you did it by changing into all
kinds of things eventually they made
their way to the king of silence you
need a crown and something for the
prophecy one thing at a time first my
crown
there it is
hey presto the king of silence he was a
good king but he got very sick and along
with him the land began to suffer fields
withered walls and cities crumbled
everything to ke it and fell apart
if only the king would recover cuz if he
did so it silence sad Wieck wanted to
bring him an elixir of life just as an
old Oracle before seen John is not old
right
he's pretty timeless actually
hello there crystal ball
Seana have a ball like that sure
somewhere the mysterious Shana foretold
that sad wick was destined to save the
king but also that he would destroy
silence of course he would never believe
that he wanted to bring an elixir of
life to the kid right yes but when he
arrived at the castle he saw that Shana
was right
do you remember what awaited him in the
throne room wall turns everything around
without actually moving there was no
King in the throne room only a mirror
and when sad wit dared to look into the
earth he didn't see a sad clown with the
bubble hats instead there was a boy
struck with an illness ready to open his
eyes after a long time or to leave them
shut forever
that boy was you you were sick and
sleeping beside weak spots in silence
that was all just a dream yeah well what
is Sabbath did they smashed the mirror
and doomed his world save you you were
the King of silence
greenies
you
we're heavy liar huh damn it
meanie meanie are you okay ready
heavy artillery bombardment
after months of breakfast we where are
you
the battles rekindle expensive huh
in Turkey chica faces
my god the sakai used a spot for my
story
looks like the egg spot hatched from
Spa are you in there
greenie thank god you're alive
where are you stupid piece of junk set
off already just die already
what is that
whoa
there's stuff from silence all over the
place is this a dream hurry I have to
get Rini
oh I could jump over there if I could
overcome my fear of height or my fear in
general for that matter
Farini
by my hands hey that was only a glow I'm
not Sanok the last time I saw that armor
a cook was wearing it I hope you got out
okay
Rini what are you doing no stay right
there
Rini
come on keep going